my spanish teacher senora kennedy flat  out knew i was going to rule the world  she gave me d's she called my mom once  and said look i'm giving him d's because  if he doesn't pass language in new  jersey he can't graduate and he already  failed german freshman sophomore year  but i think he's going to be okay and as  i started getting my early success in  the wine business from page of the star  ledger and new york times localized  stuff she would always send me a letter  to the store and i would always call her  and invite her to the store and walk  around and give her wine she's my person  she really means a lot to me because it  was the only grown-up really outside of  my mom that i think really knew that i  was going to the moon